[Music]
not many people
openly criticize the electoral process
in the republic of congo
the catholic church is one of the few
institutions that has
father felician mavungu has been
arrested twice because of his activism
he was meant to be part of a team
observing sunday's presidential election
but he told us all church observers have
been blocked from monitoring the polls
in democracy on paper it is a democracy
since 1991
but in reality with such behaviors we
need to question ourselves if we really
are
in a democracy
president denny sasso ingreso has ruled
for most of the last 40 years
and he's campaigned to stay on there are
many campaign posters for sasu and guess
who in brazil
it's a big one over there another one
here another one there
there are far fewer the opposition
candidates
like this one and whenever we try and
interview people on camera
out on the streets they're scared to
talk especially
if it's anything to do with politics or
the election
across the congo river from brazoville
is kinshasa
the capital of the neighbouring
democratic republic of congo
where the catholic church also played a
role in campaigning for elections to be
held three years ago
many of the protests were violently put
down
reverend bosela was involved in that
campaign
we met him training church leaders on
elections in brazil
before they were banned from observing
you have to raise voice
if the human dignity is ignored
the church have to raise voice
everything on the brazzerville side of
the river
is much more tightly controlled soldiers
already voted ahead of sunday's election
activists say their polls were not
transparent
but the president of the electoral
commission who's also the chief justice
insisted the republic of congo is a
democracy
absolutely if not you would not be here
interviewing president of the electoral
commission
if not there would be verbal criticisms
made against the president of the
electoral commission
felician says he's monitored elections
for more than 10 years
before being blocked
[Music]
and the churches were some of the only
election observers here that anyone
thought
might be critical of irregularities in
sunday's poll
malcolm webb al jazeera brazerville
republic of congo